big final fantasy news could be coming
next month and battlefield 2042's first
season has a solid release window
during a stream for final fantasy vii
the first soldier mobile battle royale
game director tetsuya nomura said that
there will be some announcements
surrounding final fantasy vii in june
this could be a sign that square enix
will release information about part two
of final fantasy vii remake as it
suggests that the game would be revealed
sometime during its anniversary year
june is also a significant month as it
contains showcases and events where e3
traditionally takes place summer games
fest airs on june 9th while the xbox and
bethesda showcase is june 12th though
final fantasy remake has not seen an
xbox release it could be a possibility
additionally nemours said he'd like to
show the new trailer for final fantasy
16 soon and it could be revealed
alongside final fantasy 7 remake part
2's news as well since final fantasy 16
is a timed playstation 5 exclusive and
final fantasy vii remake is currently a
playstation console exclusive they could
potentially appear at a future state of
play showcase too make some bets in the
comments what year do you think final
fantasy 7 remake part 2 is dropping my
guess is early 2024 but alright
battlefield fans strap on a party hat
and get ready to throw some confetti
because the wait for 2042's delayed
season 1 is almost over developer dice
confirmed today that the first season is
expected to launch in early june season
1 will be the first of four seasons
coming to the game in the span of 12
months players can expect four new
specialists new maps and quote more
completely new content throughout the
four seasons dice said it will share a
full overview and patch notes for season
1 as it draws closer the game's next
update version 4.1 is launching tomorrow
aka may 19th the focus of this new patch
is to deliver even more fixes and more
quality of life improvements for example
it removes 120 player breakthrough
because it wasn't working as intended
and also includes some balance changes
for weapons and specialists some of
these key changes includes a nerf for
the boris sg36 sentry gun and another
nerf of sorts for angel who can no
longer give armor plates to teammates
via his supply bag additionally all
stock weapons should now have better
handling by way of improved base recoil
i'll include a link to the full list of
patch notes in the description below and
if you're thinking of jumping ship on
battlefield and getting into call of
duty instead well you're in luck call of
duty vanguard's multiplayer mode is
having a free access week starting today
may 18th until may 24th the event will
include all maps and modes including
season three's new mayhem map vanguard's
large-scale arms race objective mode the
popular ship house playlist and more
leave a comment letting me know if you
play first-person shooters with inverted
controls and i'll see you tomorrow